[Music]
americans are traveling again
but if your summer travel plans involve
a rental car be prepared for long lines
and sticker shock i think it's all over
the country
uh there isn't one area where you can
find a cheap rental car
using a car right now is expensive
whether you're buying it
or renting it according to the travel
website kayak
rental car prices in the first two weeks
of june are up
89 for the july fourth weekend compared
to with the same dates
in 2019 and as much as 300 percent
in some places but even if you decide to
pony up the additional cash for a
vehicle
many reservations are simply not being
honored by rental agencies
and travelers have reported showing up
at rental counters only to be turned
away
because there aren't enough cars on the
lot
so why have rental cars become so
expensive
and how long can we expect these high
prices to last
it's a pretty classic supply and demand
issue there are not a lot of rental cars
to go around
because these companies downsized their
fleets when nobody was using them
the beginning of the pandemic travel of
any kind really
collapse a particularly air travel which
the rental car companies
rely on very heavily uh and so there was
this
situation where they had to react very
quickly
to a very rapid
drop in demand for months the pandemic
transformed airports into ghost towns
which in turn wiped out about two-thirds
of the rental car business
what happens is all of the rental car
companies react quickly
sell off their cars before they lose too
much value
downsize their fleets cut costs downsize
their staff
i mean find every way to pinch
pennies and stay alive really it was a
it was a make or break moment for these
companies
to survive many rental car agencies sold
off large parts of their fleet
it's a great time to sell cars too
because new car production
has still still hasn't normalized so
they sold a lot of cars
to build cash flow but then they also
sold cars
in order to right size to demand and so
you had a double whammy
uh in terms of supply getting cut and
then you also had hertz go bankrupt
[Music]
in may of 2020 hertz filed for
bankruptcy
but missouri sees a silver lining in the
disruption covett was a blessing in
disguise for this industry because it
created pricing discipline and supply
discipline
these companies basically had to cut
their fleet size down
by 35 so this was a dysfunctional
oligopoly
uh supply was never tight this summer
consumer demand has returned and now a
new problem has arisen
there's an extreme shortage of new cars
when demand came back
it did not trickle back it came back
almost overnight
and you have these companies that have
right sized themselves
to a market that basically wasn't using
them before
uh and they just weren't prepared
we're also hearing is that these
companies are so desperate to get
sleep that they're buying cars in the
used car market
which is in the auction market so don't
be surprised if you get into some rental
car that has a lot more miles on it
exacerbating the car shortage issue is
another shortage
semiconductors automakers have said the
production of new vehicles has been
slowed
because of chip shortages new car
production with a chip shortage isn't
going to normalize
until q4 so for these companies it's
going to be very tough to add fleet back
this year and so this year pricing is
going to remain very high
in separate statements to the wall
street journal both hertz and enterprise
acknowledge that customers might have a
tougher time securing a rental because
of the spike in demand
enterprise wrote while still below
pre-pandemic fleet levels
our fleet is not down significantly a
key challenge right now
is the global chip shortage impacting
new car availability
hertz wrote the microchip shortage is
also affecting the car rental industry
but hertz is working closely with our
automotive partners to add new vehicles
to our fleet
as quickly as possible while also moving
vehicles to the areas with highest
demand
if you have to rent a car this summer
missouri recommends booking early
and booking backwards typically
travelers book flights or hotels first
but that strategy won't work this year
you essentially you just have to book in
advance
and and kind of pay up for it and be
prepared for that
uh you know if you're lucky enough to
get one